yeah welcome to this video play I rias
too i think i know the sky markings
bokkeum yeah I Simone I'm not sure I
think he's doing stuff watches com not
taken ok you got a double fianchetto and
let's make it a quadruple fianchetto
it's not the most exciting opening I am
I'm the first to admit that oops okay
and cat don't see that too often they
all take on they all take on deform this
maybe don't want to spend too much time
trying to do something extraordinary in
in the opening in such an ordinary
position okay takes just ripped adjust
them Knight takes or Bishop tanks now if
we should take second probably also just
drop it back
yeah 9292 night XD to Bishop e7 night f1
look a chemical queen of one who quite
strange others but probably completely
idiotic to spend any time on Knight c3
can take f2 even
ok
yeah the some position can very often
transpose into one hedgehog style of
style of position takes I'm not sure if
I can avoid all those traits it doesn't
look too bad I think yeah but taking sm
now and probably not really in
threatening to take it but anyway maybe
maybe maybe mmmm maybe i'm able to at
least Im get a 935 after the exchange
night takes 95 there are some pieces
exchange this is quite often in this
structure to White's advantage so for
some reason h4 h5 is also an idea yeah
actually like this what seems to be in
quite decent shape this queen is nicer
to always put some pressure on this pawn
on only 700 it can go to h6 plus h for
hof group h5 a rope d5 with the idea to
support h5 mm-hmm it's not so bad ok
here we go
it goes night 26 intending group c 5 i
play night d 50 i can take e 7 now
they're a big trick don't think so rook
e8 i can i can just wait where do i buy
just just a second just a second maybe
95 yeah okay let's just grab this rookie
826 I mean I'm threat I'm covering e2
it's really nothing Adam mum threatening
d7 now
hd5 this is not working why is this not
working Knight f6 or 94 94 even 94s for
a bachelor even know keeping the D file
open so rudely 6i can answer with just
24 or 25 I'm sure yeah 193 he wants to
play 93 I can do that you do that oops
didn't think about that move
okay if it takes a goon is he
threatening something really taking here
take g4 take a 3m it is a threat okay
then now I mean not not a real threat
but I need to do something at least this
covers this gets out of the fork yeah
should be ok probably needs to take now
only form yeah I probably could have
played something substantially better
before but it still should win
threatening 96 and and some stuff now
not sure I can avoid f takes before I
don't really think again and if it does
that I just take the the night
cakes on e4 Quincy phone takes every
Queen 03 and that's Queen D 5 4 400 porn
check and I've got two extra points it
should be sufficient I hope but no no
move coming yeah this is some one of the
better practical choice I guess mmm what
to do now look here ok Knight f6 s may
be coming
look d 194 look the eight is the big
discovered check don't really see it and
II on c3 no not even though they didn't
see her a big check coming 96 96 Jesus
Christ 96 ah what the what the heck okay
it keeps it keeps an extra porn at least
What nonsense game hell jack
no is who is going to f8 Jesus I cannot
believe this I really cannot what a game
okay I mean if you if you have this kind
of game for I know in some tournament
for money people will suspect you're
cheating yeah I simply I simply thought
he needs to go to a jade I didn't it was
a pre move I can just I can just go back
here and I'm playing with an extra porn
and who just just better I thought
somehow I didn't didn't think of King
evade of course before I just I
overlooked 96 and and stuff TM rooty 7
is plus 7 yeah why shouldn't it be twin
c6 root system and resins actually this
kind of stuff her son and just
completely dead and I was even a head on
the clock what how long okay let's let's
play some some new game